we're in New York we're in a city that
is super Monday that is a wonder of the
world and it is a city in which the
physical layout of the city is also a
wonder and in some sense it reminds us
of how extremely difficult it is to
handle 8 plus million people on this
very sort of narrows amount amount of
land and infrastructure makes that
possible help us think through it so
what are the problems that the New
York's most important forms of
infrastructure are trying to solve
well I guess the most important thing
which which goes way back is that New
York City is more than just the skinny
island so you can't fit 8 million people
on Manhattan you can fit it in five
boroughs but those five boroughs are of
course not connected by land so probably
the most important infrastructure in New
York is actually the bridges and tunnels
that connect and weave it together
between Brooklyn Queens and Manhattan
between Bronx and Manhattan then of
course between Staten Island and
Brooklyn so without the bridges and the
tunnels you really don't have a city
that can have five boroughs absolutely
which reminds us that water is both New
York's blessing but also its curse so
it's starts right with the need to get
goods into and out of the city right
because this is a harbor so I guess it
starts with the wharves can you tell us
a bit about about 17th and 18th century
wharves well New York really started as
a port I mean most most of the oldest
cities in the world started as turning
his points because trade was so
important but it literally was just a a
drop-off point for you know the Dutch
West India Company because they wanted
to go and trade and so this was a
convenient harbor and everything started
from there the harbor started in a place
where you would not know it now it
started on the the Lower East Side and
around where the Seaport is which is now
a tourist attraction as opposed to
working Seaport but in the 18th century
and certainly in the 19th century there
was a dock where a wharf at the end of
every street if you can imagine that
partly for Freight partly for people
they were also moving across from New
Jersey to New Yorker from Brooklyn to
New York because of course at that time
there were no bridges and tunnels then
gradually we started having horse drawn
on buses and other you know forms of
transportation to move you uptown who
the north-south correct correct
so the horse-drawn carriages private
cars stagecoach had started with
stagecoaches moved to streetcars
eventually they actually ran in tracks
on the road
was wonderful except that there was no
there were no rules so you had people's
private carriages and then you had the
street cards and then you eventually
would have these steam drawn vehicles
down the street and at some point
somebody realized that it was totally
totally chaotic well in the in the
middle of the 19th century because of
course steam you know form steamboat and
then steam came in and steam was not
only powered things on the streets
ultimately the first elevated trains
when people decided the streets were too
crowded they needed to put some mobility
up the original elevated trains were of
course steam as well which was very
dirty and very noisy and very sad for
the people
we're walking underneath them so you can
imagine that the streets became more
chaotic and then you added a whole other
layer on top before you edit a layer
underground cars also came to the city
and you know were a source of both added
mobility and continual heartache tell me
about that what how did the city deal
with cars what how did they they
revolutionized a lot of what Robert
Moses oh it's a good chapter in a bad
chapter in some sense I mean Robert
Moses was famous for building most of
the highways and bridges and parkways
originally remember he was commissioner
parks so he did you know Park ways that
allowed people to recreate it wasn't to
get anywhere it was to get out of the
city and enjoy the green spaces that
were around the city they ultimately
became highways and roadways too for
that were much more functional in
purpose so those roadways not only
ranked Manhattan they went out to Long
Island they went you know in all sorts
of places and they were great until the
1950s 1960s and thanks to a lot of other
federal government policies they
actually allowed the suburbs to grow in
New York City to somewhat hollow out
certainly Manhattan to hollow out during
a period of time when the city really
needed residents and the taxes that
those brought so those roads were great
in terms of allowing people to get to
the beach into the you know the great
green spaces beyond they were not so
great as you know sort of vehicles for
essentially promoting growth in the
suburbs
you